when you get into this article um
i'll i'll just read a bit of this and uh
you know you can just think to yourself
what what is the vibe that i'm getting
from this article about this paper
all right so it starts in a massive
meta-analysis that was years in the
making psychologists from the university
of durham and the university of saint
andrews in the united kingdom explored
how six masculine traits a deep voice
height testosterone levels facial
masculinity finger digit ratio and
strength muscularity impacted men's
mating and reproductive success
one trait was the clear winner so okay
we're one paragraph in uh you know it's
saying massive meta-analysis years in
the making like really hyping this up
and
one trait is the clear winner so that
that's leaving you with the implication
that this is
uh something you can really take to the
bank and also that that one particular
thing
uh is is having a far larger magnitude
of an effect than anything else yeah so
for mating success
it is true that body masculinity which
was a composite measure of strength and
muscularity uh
what did have the strongest association
with mating success well there you go uh
and so just based on that little
well not snippet like basically the
whole article that i just read you just
kind of think to yourself like based on
how that article was worded how strong
of an association do you think there was
between body masculinity and mating
success you know probably at least a
moderate correlation maybe even a strong
correlation but no no dear listener
we're talking about an r value of 0.113
and so
you may be asking what does that mean
how do i interpret that so you can
square an r value and get uh what is
very logically called an r-squared value
um or coefficient of determination which
basically tells you
how much shared variance there is
between uh two measurements sometimes uh
sometimes that will be phrased as
how much does variation in one trait uh
or one measure explain variation in
another measure so the r squared value
we're looking at here
is 0.017
so basically like 1.7
of the variance in in uh mating success
is explained by body masculinity uh and
you i hope you're not thinking how much
is one point eight percent because it's
not much yeah yeah for for context here
like
if you were gonna pretend that you had a
model that perfectly predicted an
outcome
you would intuitively need the r squared
of the entire model together to be 100
you have to predict 100 of the variance
in the outcome so yeah if you are
predicting
less than 2 percent of the variance in
the outcome
uh
that reflects the strength of the
relationship and the confidence level
you have if you say oh wow well it if i
manipulate that variable you know what
kind of an impact will that have on the
outcome yeah yeah so all of which is to
say this is
uh a tremendous example of something we
talk about from time to time where
if you have enough data going into an
analysis
it's very easy to find things that are
statistically significant but
statistical significance and actual
practical relevance are two very
different things um
so
you know something that with in a meadow
with 177 000 subjects is predictive of a
particular outcome uh
you know if the strength of that
association is as weak as what we're
observing here then like
the the actual practical relevance of
that outcome uh in your life very well
could be and probably would be
effectively nothing uh and so like
yeah this is uh
you know it's
it's a study that i think if you
interpret it well uh
basically means that like these things
maybe there's some some degree of
predictive value in a large enough
population but like the practical
relevance to any discrete individual is
is virtually none but yeah so the the
biggest takeaway here is uh
one for the fellas uh
like just do you if you if you feel
insecure like oh man like uh one one of
the other things to note um like i i
already mentioned this but i i really
focused
most of this discussion on on the body
masculinity bit because that was the
part that they
uh
that the article really really harped on
um
but yeah like if you're a short king out
there and you see this article being
shared around and you're like oh man it
also said that that height uh was a
predictor of of mating success where
where taller people have it better uh
that was another statistically
significant relationship with an even
lower r value that was an r of
.057 so
i mean that would be an r squared value
of like half a percent or like point
point three percent uh so once again
like if you're a short king and you're
like oh no like the it's it's never
going to work out for me the
height was not predictive of mating
success for all intents and purposes uh
if you're like oh no i'm uh
self-conscious about the fact that my
pointer finger is longer than my ring
finger and that means i have low t and
that means no woman will ever love me
one
if that's a thought that's gone through
your head you consume too much in-cell
content stop it uh yeah or if you're
like oh no i don't have a strong jawline
also don't [ __ ] worry about it not
predictive uh yeah just like just like
chill out be you be a cool person treat
people well and uh yeah stuff should
work out
good advice